The answer is 01011010.
Let me explain why.
Remember that we're using CBC mode encryption.
The value of ciphertext block i is the result of encrypting, using the key.
The value of ciphertext block i -1 XORed with message block i.
For the first block of the second message, that's going to be c0'.
It's the result of encrypting the value of the previous block,
and this was the initialization vector for the first block.
For this one, it's the last block in the previous message.
That was the block we call c(n-1).
That's XORed with message block 0.
Here is the danger. The adversary actually knows this value.
That means the adversary can pick a message value so the value of c0' reveals something.
That means it has to be an input to the encryption.
We're assuming the adversary can't break the encryption.
But it has to be an input to the encryption the adversary already knows what
the expected result is.
The adversary knows the encryptions of all the blocks in the previous message,
and we know from the way CBC worked, if we want to learn the value of m4--
m4 was encrypted in the original message using the value here.
This was ciphertext 3--the previous ciphertext block--
and that was encrypted and it produces output--ciphertext block 4.
That means if we can feed into this result, that means if we can make the value of this
equal to the result of c3 XORed with m4--we don't know m4,
but we can make it our guess for m4.
We're going to XOR it with our guess for m*--m4.
If that's the input to the encryption function, then we'll be able to look at the output
and see if it matches c4.
To make that the input, we have this IV, which is really the last block in the previous message.
We can just XOR that out.
What we're going to pass in is the guess XORed with the known value of c3
XORed with this value.
With the values I've chosen, c3 is this, m* is all zeros, so we don't need to worry about that
in the XOR, and c(n-1)--the last ciphertext block--is all the 1s.
That's going to flip the first 5 bits. That's why we get this value.
Let's see what happens when that value is used for m0.
What we're going to get for ciphertext block 0 is the result of encrypting
the known value of ciphertext block n -1 with this result, which is c3.
Now this is XORed so that same values cancel out.
That means the result is the result of encrypting c3
XORed with m*.
That's the same as we were doing here.
That's encrypting m4 XORed with c3.
We know what c3 is. We could construct this message to pass in.
We don't know what m4 is, but we know if this result is the same,
then this should be the same as ciphertext block 4.
That would give us the answer to the question was m4 equal to m*.
Of course, we can generalize this.
If we can pick the value of m0' to be the XOR of the last ciphertext block
and the one before the one we want to guess and our guess,
that means what we learn if the ciphertext block that results from the new message
is equal to ciphertext block i, then we know that block mi is equal to m*.